so where I'm gonna start with is just to
make sure I get everything in there
the right units okay SI unit sir R
equals hundred meters no problems there
30 kilometer are you're always going to
get things in km/h so get used to the
conversion right so what's this thirty
six thousand meters and by now we're
used to the fact that how many seconds
are there in an hour
3600 so that's kind of convenient that's
nice all right the mass is 80 kilograms
so now I'm trying to resolve all the
forces and like I said you've got a
horizontal one and a vertical one in
fact you can go straight back to here
right so vertically what's going on
vertically the normal it's just going to
be equal to the mass times gravity
that's it and you're talking in use
right I suppose if you were doing a
kilogram weight it'd be different but
that's that it was simple that's all you
need to do okay
likewise when you're working out the
friction force you're gonna go here MB
squared on are you know what all of
these pieces are all right you got your
80 at M V squared is gonna be a hundred
and AH is also a hundred but slightly
suspicious that it's the same note but
it's not really because I haven't
multiplied by gravity in this case okay
so now we've gotta go and work out the
angle but because we did our work here
all you need to do is take back this and
then see if you get a reasonable result
at the end right so you're saying this
is papi no theta equals 10 inverse of a
hundred on a hundred G right so this is
just 1 over 9.8 or whatever you like now
I think clustered nearest minute what
did you get and was it an intelligible
Anton does it make sense someone anyone
dream I think it's you had this right
okay now does this make sense as an
answer is it within a reasonable domain
yeah I think it's just like without I
wrap it up just like without bank tracks
right you're not having huge angles here
to get the desired effect he's going
quite fast for a cyclist right and he
only needs to lean this far which by the
way tells you a little bit about the
cyclist I showed you how far he was
leaning and therefore how fast he was
going right likewise if you think about
where is it ah here right so our piece
here in the denominator so what happened
is I decrease off as I decrease our
right this whole thing is increasing in
size which means the angle is also
increasing in size that makes sense
decrease our it's a tighter turn so
you've got a lean in harder does that
make sense
the same is away from the vertical so
you're going further robot right so they
go